the jurogan experience when you were
thinking about coming back i remember um
there was that conversation with you
where there was there was a potential
comeback fight with ronda yeah how
serious was that it was very serious
what stopped it from happening so
you know how like you know i went um i'm
living in l.a
um i used to train out of uh randy
coutures in um vegas and i had my whole
group there right i had scott berry jiu
jitsu i i don't know where he went i
think he's like disappeared into the
woods or something remember on the mat
yeah yeah he used to own that store in
las vegas yeah
him and his brother i don't know where
he is
like i he's like a mountain man now
um chris ben javazzi he's a boxing coach
um used to be you know v bucks and coach
um still you'll see him um yeah he's
he's pretty great
so i had my whole team in
vegas so when randy or when dana white
and lorenzo they invited me out finally
like you know
this had been like five years ago they
said hey we'd like to offer you like you
know a million dollar fight with rhonda
and i was like damn what took you guys
so long like
um
what i told what i had told uh dana and
lorenzo at that time was you know i
don't have a team i don't even have an
idea of a team i don't have a gym
i have um you know i don't think me and
kevin were together at that time i
didn't have any connection into
you know where i would do this fight
camp and i knew you know with the weight
and everything it was going to take me a
good
it would take me three months to get the
weight stabilized and then it would take
me um four months to actually be in like
fight camp you know what i mean um just
to get back into it i hadn't fought at
that time almost like a decade
so um
i just i asked dana if he could just
please keep it quiet you know just don't
bring up my name
you know give me the time to at a six
month time and i of course raised them
all yeah
it's not even reasonable you really need
like a year right well yeah but i was
you know i felt like i could at that
point moment i feel like six months
what do you know you know dude
he was like
and i've got gina chrono and it's gonna
give me a v against ronda rousey and he
started pumping it out on the you know
twitter and he pumped it out in the
interviews and i was like whoa whoa like
calm down like
first of all i don't even know who i'm
gonna train with so now you've made it
harder for me to walk into a gym and
just get comfortable with people because
now everybody knows i'm looking for a
team i'm looking for something right and
it's going to be a very high profile
yeah and so now it made everything so
much more difficult and
you know like that's where we didn't get
along for a second i was like dude like
right like quiet down like if you just
quiet down i can find a team and i can
get organized
and then
he said something pretty aggressive over
text messages i'm sure you know he he
does that and um
i was just like okay i'm not gonna do
that like it was very simple for me like
that was gonna be something for me um
and i was excited to be back in that
world and i was excited to do something
like that i respect ronda and
i thought that was exciting um but
after like
you just can't like go back in that
world and feel instantly disrespected on
so many levels so i was like
i'm cool i'm gonna go and then i think
another movie came up and i was like
sweet i'll just go do this movie then
you know like i'm not gonna i don't need
to be disrespected you know so that's
that's how that story went
you didn't have any inclination to have
another fight you just wanted to have
the ronda rousey fight
i mean i think when you fight you are
constantly fighting
i have a bag in my you know downstairs
in my
garage like i i'm you know on the
treadmill and constantly fighting people
in my head and having a comeback fight
all the time how old do you know i'm 40.
so do you think you would still do it i
mean i still can't even say that i
wouldn't you know because you know
rhonda said yeah that you're the one i
know and honestly i i feel like she's
the one as well if i wanted to you know
let's go ladies let's [ __ ] go if you
wanted to do it get me a dietitian
because i have to do that or chop off in
my entire leg i'm sure there's people
she said she'd fight you at 205. i know
you know me i or you don't know me i
would not it would be an equal weighted
you know oh i'm sure i know it would be
professional i i have no interest in
being like uh if you wanted to do it
though now it's like
last call yeah and you know what i when
when she said that i'm like you know i'm
so focused on um my dreams in in movie
making but i also
i guess you just never
you never lose that want to do it and
you and for me i i've been looking for
something to train for to get my body
back and and where i want it to be
and so there's just been with this
little kind of this little
thing on my shoulders like well you
could you could train and you could get
yourself where you want to be and use
that as your focus
you